Ooh,
it's so good though.
It is good.
It's smooth.
I like the cinnamon too.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And it's in a party drink for real tequila enthusiasts though.
Is that like sacrilege?
Is that like an electric Mustang?
Oh yeah.
But that's what the monkey has always done.
Yeah.
You know,
it's like playing the golf thing outside of the launch gas monkey golf apparel
line.
And so I'll be wearing a golf shirt out there and it's,
it's pretty crazy.
It's a got a skull and all kinds of crap or whatever.
But uh,
whether I'm pushing the envelope as the monkey is,
our tagline is snap and teas and fill in holes.
Now when you bring that to the country club to people say,
sir,
that attire is unforgivable here.
Oh yeah.
For sure.
I've been thrown out of my own country club plenty of times and I've bought a
lot of golf carts cause I've crashed him cause I thought it was fun and it got
thrown out of your own country club a bunch of time.
Really?
For what?
Just raising too much.
Hell it,
you know,
I'm the,
it almost like the old Rodney daydreaming movies,
you know,
it's like,
sorry,
you can't do that in here.
And I was like,
well,
I'm going to do it twice.
Caddyshack all time.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Now what did they say to you?
Uh,
just,
you know,
they usually just take me home because you know,
live on the course,
so they'll drive me down there.
You have a house on the course?
I did.
I lived downtown in Dallas now,
but,
uh,
the worst one was I decided to drop my Harley home on the golf course.
One nine agreements.
I stayed to the cart path.
I'm not a complete asshole,
but,
uh,
I did drive it home at about one 30 or two in the morning and my house is
probably the furthest house from the clubhouse.
And that thing is freaking loud when you're in that,
you know,
this trench of a golf course.
Right.
The cops were waiting on me when I got home,
but thank God they were in the cops.
I was like,
you can't do anything.
I'm going inside fake golf course cops.
Yeah.
You know,
the community cops community cobb's that's adorable.
I had a good one for you actually got arrested at this country club.
Well at my house for,
I wouldn't say arrested because they ended up letting me go,
but they did come cuff me and put me away.
Um,
the,
um,
we're coming home from Christmas extravaganza,
which I do with my buddies every year.
Right before Christmas we get a big garden pile in and we go Christmas shopping
for our families.
And what have you coming home loaded?
I supposedly threw a burrito from taco bell or something and hit the guard.
So there's four,
three or four of my buddies.
We get to my house,
we pig out on Shitty Taco bell food,
you know,
until everybody passes out.
And the next thing I know the cop lights are,
aren't banging on the door.
Get out of here.
I'm,
I come to the door going,
hey,
why,
you know,
after you've been drinking and he'd do a bunch of have food,
you're fucking gone.
And,
uh,
so long story short,
they said,
well,
you're going to be arrested for assault.
If you look,
go ahead and uh,
say you're sorry to this guy saw it with a burrito.
Correct.
Right.
And by the,
and so if you charge a man with a salt,
because he throws a Burrito at you,
you should,
you should turn in your card.
But we,
we watch the tape.
It was not like throwing it at him.
It's not like I've barely with a baseball right here.
I like chunked it to him to eat.
But he didn't see it coming until it like slapped him and fell down.
So they,
they cuffed me,
they take me down to the guard house.
Yeah,
they put me in the back of the cop car.
Kofi cops.
No,
these are real.
It's a real cop.
He filed a report and a,
so this is how stupid it gets by then.
I'm so fricking loaded.
Right.
And I get there and the Burrito is still on the ground,
like it's evidence or some shit.
And they're telling me,
I got to apologize to this guy and all I can focus on this.
There's a perfectly good fucking burrito around here.
I'm going to eat this burrito.
So I sit down and literally start eating the Burrito God and you're like,
please just tell him you're sorry so can go back home.
And I'm like,
okay.
So I tell him,
I'm sorry,
I'm still eating a burrito.
And they just left me there like a mile from my house at the guard shack.
You walked home with mile drunk.
See The guy since then?
Oh Gosh.
Now I was like,
dude,
that was perfectly,
I mean back,
this was in the days before.
The sprinters are so popular,
so it was like a stretch limo,
which is,
you know,
you just really don't ride it anymore.
And I was like,
that's a hell of a shot.
Came out of the back window 120 inches up to the front,
hit the gas,
cleared the fucking chest.
I should get a medal for that.
Assault.
Might be a plus in here.
Assault with a Burrito is probably the first time that we've had that are here
and you're a little a podcast room.
I definitely think it's the first time.
It seems like you'd just be able to say,
Hey,
I just threw it to you because I was drunk.
I thought you were hungry.
This is really what it was.
There's one,
I mean you can hear me on the video going,
hey,
you want a burrito?
And uh,
it,
it was pretty ridiculous.
The guy got his man card Yang for sure.
Yeah.
What someone calls a salt.
Like how dare you.
Some people get beaten to a pulp and you call them a Taco Bell Burrito flying
your way.
That thing costs a dollar 99 dude
and it's barely meet.
We were going over like how much of like there's a ruling on how much meat it
actually has to be,
we can call it a beef Burrito,
but there's fillers in that shit.
Like what is the filler was like silicone or something like that.
But it's something ridiculous.
Like 34% of it is not actually meet.
That's why,
I mean,
that was 10 years ago.
Yeah.
I just don't eat fast food 80% for the internet.
They can pretend it's meat.
Well,
the cool thing,
Taco bell now starting to open all their ones up with bars inside there.
What?
Yeah.
Well that's good for business.
You know,
get people more drunks.
They don't care what the food tastes like.
Actually get them all tanked up feeling some burritos and send them on their
way.